hey next time manic smear test
so I got my first letter for my smear
test from my doctor when I was 25 in
fact it was two weeks before I turned 24
it was actually the same for me I when
it came through I was like I'm a woman
yeah I was like your great birthday
presents mere a so I picked it straight
away I have had STI checks in the past
and I knew it was going to be quite
similar to that yeah kind of the same
routine and I wasn't that nervous so I
went along and my a results came back
abnormal which then led to the whole
process of me having colposcopy x' let's
treatment to try and get rid of my
precancerous cells on my cervix yeah it
was exactly the same for me so when I
was about 21 years old I went to the
doctor because I was getting some
symptoms which were pointing towards you
know like cervical cancer sort of thing
what like spotting like okay periods and
things like that so I went to the doctor
and I asked if I could have a smear test
you came but they said because of my age
I was only 21 and you're not supposed to
happen to or 25 and so anyway I waited
and two weeks before my 25th birthday I
got a letter so it's like happy birthday
it's time to give me a test you know I
know
so were you like embarrassed about going
for you smear cuz I wasn't at all and
the only concern I had was like what do
I wear do I wear jeans so I went would I
wear a long skirt so I can roll it hurt
like I don't really know and then I
think do I leave my socks on do I take
them off and then I had all these things
around in my head so I was a bit like
all over the place with it but yeah I
was just more worried it would hurt I
was worried about the pain for sure I
wasn't at all embarrassed about my
vagina I was a bit like should I shave
shouldn't I like what service but they
see it all that all day every day these
people that are doing this much yeah
exactly and the whole like agreement
thing alike do i I don't look like I've
tried too hard like I'm you know it's
not like you know it's my first time
meeting some video you know fair also is
a very daunting intimate thing it like
even with a partner you don't just sit
there with your legs open and have them
stare at ya in between like they just
yeah it's it's very intimate and I think
that freaks a lot of girls out I've got
friends who have
you know I'm a bit worried about going
because and even bikini waxes and things
like that yeah
they're worried about what they look
like down there and do they look like
all the other ones that these like
nurses or waxes are gonna see yeah it's
true like I don't know what any of my
friends though it's not the sort of
thing that you look like I only know my
own so yeah I understand how that can be
really worrying going for your smear and
being like am i normal but you know what
I found no woman is the same everyone is
unique in their own right and so I think
it's it remember that what you're going
for your smearing yeah will stop any
embarrassment and we've got some props
happening I'm so excited about me so
this is the it's not like a what's it
called effect scale erm there are two
different sizes this one's a normal one
and this one is the virgin one I
actually I think ya asked for the virgin
one of my first time just cuz I was so
nervous yeah and you can ask for the
smaller ones I read a story once about
this woman who used her like toddlers
flannel play flannel to clean up a bit
before her smear test and she got there
and she realized she was covered in
glitter
I know College is a bit like whoa you've
made next time man it's me a taste I got
a letter two weeks later and I thought
when I got it it was quite a chunky
letter so I thought ice is not good news
it said that I had it's cause severe
disc Airy osseous I think is how you say
it but that's like the most so you can
have like mild moderate or severe and I
was like the worst and make it tell that
just from your first meals from my smear
yeah I don't know how it must have been
petrifying I was really scared because I
thought oh my gosh this is my first one
like how long has it been like that for
if you know and especially because I'd
wanted a smear test earlier on in life
when I was about 21 I thought you know
what if all these like last four years
it's been getting worse and worse
did you get the letter you got it
through letter or phone calls yeah I I
think I've got a letter through and
saying that there were abnormalities and
I freaked out I panic I'm at I think I'm
a bit of a hypochondriac I won't worry
about it and then obviously get onto
Google and you like what does happen
what does that mean like but I booked in
for my compost cookie straight after
remember them sending me like pamphlets
about a compost cream yeah what was
going to happen and but yeah I was
petrified so I'm guessing I have had HPV
as well tonight yeah I think it did
it said cm3 in my yeah so CN three is to
do with the cell changes I think so
that's the worst sign so that's the same
as what I had as well yeah and but then
when they do a perhaps smear they you're
sometimes get a result where all say you
also tested positive for HPV and which I
think I'm going to try and say there
stands for the human papillomavirus
basically they think like eighty to
ninety percent of people who are
sexually active will have it at some
point in their lives but your body can
get rid of it yeah by itself over the
course of two years yeah
so that's why they don't really check
for it in like STI checks or anything
like that because your immune system
will just fight off but there are so
many different strains of it and a few
of the strains can cause the
precancerous cells and I think like
pretty much all cervical cancer cases
will have been triggered and caused by
HPV I think though it's nothing to be
ashamed about
no definitely not it's so you don't just
get it from sexual contact it is
sometimes just skin-to-skin gel so
you're probably going to be exposed to
at some point in your life anyway so
basically don't freak out that your
partner is cheating on ya definitely not
the case that isn't the case at all you
can catch it yeah a number of ways so I
took my men with me to Michael FAAST
copay and they said they were going to
take some biopsies but on the on the
camera the nurse could actually see that
they were like potentially precancerous
cells there from the color changes and
the like lotion that they bought not
lotion was the the dye life in ago it's
like some sort of liquid it stink it
stings a little bit but it's not yeah so
they could see and they said to me right
you can have the let's treatment here
right now wow I didn't get any time to
prepare for that so you had it straight
away yes so in my first co-op Oscar P
they said yeah I think you know instead
of getting you back in have the let's
treatment then which is basically I can
remove one let stands for it's like
electronic loop yeah I see the kind of
zap them off
I took my mum with me she was looking at
the screen yeah she was fascinated with
like watching my service and I
won't have any part of that I don't want
to see I think it would have made me
freak out a bit more but the nurse was
like look you've got a pretty flower
pattern on your cervix and I was like
that means it's bad like something don't
want the pattern you want nice clear
scream and then when they're doing the
removal of the bad cells it just feels
like bad hair earrings I would recommend
as well taking a sanitary towel along
with you just in case there is bleeding
for the COPO Skippy unless they're 100%
be bleeding afterwards yeah definitely
mine which I was bleeding out for a long
and there's stuff like you can't have a
bath after flike a Monday you can't and
you can't have sex for a long time after
you have a let's treatment and a corpus
cookie as well I think it's six six
weeks you can't have a sex war
afterwards or bath I just miss the bath
as well I really did I like all you want
after you've had something like that
done it's just a nice warm bath I mean
you'd feel better yeah
from beginning to end from like my first
mate test to when I got the all-clear it
was about two years yeah same for me it
was a long process
yeah after that let's treatment then you
wait three months again for a smear but
then I was quite unlucky because on my
follow-up smear to that one they hadn't
quite got enough cells on there so it's
actually this little thing so this is
what goes in when you have a smear test
and they kind of wiggle it around like
that to collect all the cells on the end
of here it's like a little brush about
two years after it all kind of started I
finally got a result back that said okay
now you're all clear now and you don't
have to come and see us again for three
years and I was so really best I was so
relieved yeah I thought it was never
gonna end my next meal is coming up
perhaps this year oh I know I'm excited
you're excited yeah I can't wait I'm
just praying for the same result yeah
but if there was bad results I know what
to expect now yeah so I wouldn't be
frightened about it I would just you
know and we're still here yeah it's so
much easier than not going at all and
then finding out too late that you have
got cancer cells on your service yes I
think a lot of people were like oh it's
never going to happen to me like it's my
first mere test I can just delay it put
it off but we are both living examples
that we went to our first smear test and
came back with
abnormalities it's so important it could
save your life and it's over so quickly
hey it's okay to have a smear test and
find out you've got abnormal results
it's really nothing to worry about the
doctors know what they're doing and it's
much better to have a smear test and
find out you've got abnormal cells there
than to not have one and not know what's
going on if you liked this video please
be sure to share and comment down below
also don't forget to subscribe to
examine YouTube channel